[Musique]
bonjour nicolas cage bonjour bertrand
cariou bonjour aux auditeurs de matinée
une première
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
pour peut participer donc à ce qu'a dit
spécial élections municipales et
communautaires alors on a déjà reçu des
représentants de différents secteurs de
la société martiniquaise nous ne
recevons pas des candidats mais des
personnes que nous avons choisie pour
qu'à s'exprime un peu sur donc ce sujet
nicolas cage
alors vous êtes tout à fait légitime
justement pour cela vous êtes une femme
de lettres vous êtes écrivaine diseuse
de parole aussi un peu slameuse je crois
conteuse aussi par moment enfin voilà
vous êtes attentive en tout cas aux
faits d'actualité de la société
martiniquaise ainsi qu attaché à son
identité culturelle de notre société y
compris dans sa dimension caribéenne et
puis on va préciser également dans que
dans une période antérieure vous avez
exercé le métier de professeur de
lettres et d'espagnol on ajoutera pour
conclure cette présentation que vous
avez eu également une formation en
journalisme
nicole cage voilà mes mais là c'est la
productrice culturel que qu'on invite la
productrice culturel que vous êtes
entretien tels des relations avec les
éditer des diverses municipalités de
l'île et des communautés d'agglomération
et bien je crois qu'on est en tant
qu'artiste en tant que producteurs
culturels en tant que format fomentateur
j'ai envie de dire culturel on est on
est dans ce petit pays lâche ce petit
espace et il est nécessaire il est
important de bien d'être au plus près
des gens et au plus près des gens mais
c'est aussi à travers les les structures
comme comme les municipalités comme les
communautés d'agglomération donc
effectivement quand j'ai un événement à
proposer ou parfois je suis sollicité
pour proposer un événement que ça soit
un récital une séance de dédicaces etc
et et c'est vrai que bon en général cela
se passe bien
en général ça se passe bien ce sont des
services et des personnes surtout qu'ils
sont dans les services administratifs
sont des personnes facilement
accessibles
y sont sensibles à ce sujet ce domaine
là enfin voilà alors évidemment en tant
qu' en tant que personnes impliquées on
peut toujours trouver à dire que ce que
ça n'est pas c'est que la place qui est
laissée à la culture justement dans
d'une façon générale c'est pas seulement
chez nous au niveau de nos communautés
et c'est de nos collectivités c'est
vraiment quelque chose au niveau
étatique etc au niveau mondial la
culture d'une façon générale n'a pas la
place
oui bien sûr et mai mais tout de même il
y a de plus en plus une volonté qui se
manifestent de bain de s'ouvrir de de
faire appel aux gens du pays pour pour
pour nourrir un peu j'ai envie de dire
l'âme de tous les citoyens
alors est ce que ces relations que vous
avez bon temps en temps toque à la porte
ou si vous êtes sollicités est-ce que ça
a pu aller et est ce que ça pourrait
aller est ce que vous vous le
souhaiteriez que ça le soit davantage
par exemple jusqu'à un partenariat ou
une forme de convention avec telle ville
ou tel organisme culturel artistique de
telle commune ou telle commune papa
précisément que j'ai eu par exemple
occasion cap nord m'avait demandé d'être
marraine de dinde un événement que
c'était le une démarche de rupture de la
fracture numérique
m le livre et mettre tous tout tous les
équipements numériques à disposition des
habitants du nord qui sont quelque part
un peu délaissé et donc il y avait ma
demandé d'être marraine en tant
qu'écrivaine de ce2 de cet événement de
ce et j'ai accepté volontiers parce que
parce que voilà par toulonnais avec ce
que l'on a bien on peut apporter sa
pierre
ben justement une
un développement de la culture de
l'éducation d'une façon générale de la
connaissance aussi alors il ya les
moyens aussi que alors on va y revenir
un peu en fin d'entretien quand je vous
demanderais si vous avez des
propositions déçoivent par rapport à ces
élections et ce qui va venir mais il
faut aussi des moyens tant financiers et
budgétaires que n'ont pas toujours les
les communes que non plus toujours
d'ailleurs les communes et quand il
s'agit de faire des économies on sait
que c'est des fois les premiers postes
sur lesquels on va la culture le sport
etc
il faut des moyens donc financier c'est
vrai et puis des moyens aussi matérielle
des lieux des lieux des lieux logistique
même si c'est en plein air on a la
chance avec notre climat de pouvoir
faire des représentations en plein air
mais enfin des lieux que ce soit des
salles des médiathèques des scènes en
fin et tout ça mais je crois que hélas
et l'inégal d'ailleurs d'une commune à
l'autre un par semaine
absolument mais mais tous par tous
parlent d'une volonté la culture c'est
aussi une question de volonté politique
je vous ai qu il ya des municipalités
qui n'ont pas beaucoup de moyens mais
qui avec les moyens qu'elles ont elles
font par exemple le le la culture au
niveau de la ville du prêcheur c'est de
cesser c'est quand même un levier qui
est qui est important donc par exemple
j'ai eu l'occasion de participer à cet
événement qui s'appelle mais songez à
deux reprises parce que j'ai un récital
qui est basée sur la mémoire sur sur le
devoir de mémoire en quelque sorte et
que j'ai été convié à deux reprises bon
évidemment les cachets ne sont pas
mirobolants mais il ya ceux il ya des
municipalités qui ont vraiment ça ce
respect de bain de l'artiste et de sa
proposition
l comment quand l'argent n'est pas là
mais il ya d'autres façons par exemple
en ce moment je suis je suis en train on
est en train de monter une de mes pièces
patrie combat donc le metteur en scène
le cantique du pays libre et donc nous
avons sollicité par exemple la ville de
fort de france il n'y a pas de moyens
financiers mais le partenariat conclu
avec la ville de fort-de-france et la
mise à disposition de
du centre andré aliker pour une
résidence de création par exemple voilà
donc les les
à partir du moment où il ya une volonté
les choses les choses peuvent se faire
et s'est articulé et ce nivelage et même
parfois avec peu de moyens ou voilà
absolument juste les moyens nécessaires
sont très bien alors évidemment nous
sommes en campagne électorale alors vous
une colle cage estimez vous que le monde
des arts et de la culture s'impliquent
grandement d'une manière générale dans
la vie politique martiniquaise des
françaises et que la lah pour ces
élections tout proche tout proche plutôt
est-ce qu'ils ont eu leur mot à dire est
ce que vous avez entendu effectivement
des acteurs et actrices culturel
certainement peut-être parce que bon on
peut pas être à la fois partout dans des
communes mais là où vous habitez vous
par exemple je crois que vous êtes un an
soit vers le françois en france voilà
voilà
et est ce que vous estimez que ça peut
aller plus loin ce qu'il faudrait ou
est-ce que vous vous vous souhaiteriez
mais pourquoi pas vous même un jour
figurer sur une liste être candidat
enfin à s'impliquer j'ai été sollicité
mais je ne je suis un moment de mon
parcours où je suis à la fois actrice
mais aussi beaucoup observatrice et donc
j'ai besoin d'une marge de manoeuvre que
n'aurait pas le fait d'être sur une
liste avec mais je crois que le ya
effectivement un
une forme de ya une forme de
désenchantement des artistes mais de la
population en général vis-à-vis de la
chose politique
parce que c'est vrai que il y a eu
tellement d'affaires tellement de de
corruption tellement de promesses non
tenues tellement de oui ce sont deux
mondes qui se qui se regarde un peu de
méfiance avec défiance parfois de
défiance et font absolument et que les
politiques n'ont pas encore réussi
justement à peut-être une question
d'intérêt question de malades de
priorité mais n'ont pas encore réussi à
faire cette démarche en direction des
artistes et du coup en quelque part il
ya toujours une chose et son et son
versant le fait que les artistes ne se
sentent pas assez soutenus assez
c'est réputé c'est considérer absolument
fait que ben de fait ils se prennent en
charge et de même qu'on ait à une
agriculture parallèle j'ai envie de dire
eh bien il y à il y un comme ça
heureusement résolument vers
organisation et ce qui va la pole pour
l'agriculture par exemple où l'écologie
d'une façon générale du point de vue de
jeu prend l'exemple d'un jeune malik mal
ça avec le jardin de la santé à
sainte-anne et les artistes sans gagner
au parc de tivoli bal des artistes ont
décidé avec leurs moyens propres de
crier d'ouvrir un espace de deux
créations mais aussi de sol etc tacle il
compte peut-être toujours un peu sur les
politiques mais une attente plus sur les
polices absolument c'est absolument
c'est ce que c'est que voilà il nous
faut conclure en résumant alors si vous
aviez un souhait pour les prochaines
années
sur le plan politique est ce que vous
auriez voulu justement en dehors de cet
intérêt peut-être plus grand et de ce
soutien
voilà et bien que une proposition oui
que que que qu'on rende alarme compte
justice à l'art parce que on astres ont
tendance à dire les artistes sont un peu
mais il n'y a pas de magie n'opère
pourtant ils ont ils ont une importance
y compris politiques et cet exemple que
j'aime souvent cités c'est le fait que
ben les écrivains et les artistes sont
souvent les premiers parmi les premières
victimes aussi de des systèmes
dictatoriaux et cet exemple que j'ai de
ce pianiste argentin qui allait jouer
qu'elle choisit de jouer du classique
pour des ouvriers et qui a été attrapé
torture et on lui a écrasé les mains
parce que voilà donc cesser c'est dire
l'importance de donc les les
les pouvoirs les dictatoriaux savent
l'importance de la culture donc il
convient que ben ben que monsieur tout
le monde et ça aussi à l'esprit
absolument
en terminant lundi quand un rendez vous
que vous donnez bientôt au public
vous pouvez en parler donc ce sera le 14
mars il s'agit d'un prochain spectacle
une sorte de performance enfin dites
nous un petit peu en quelques mois donc
aimé agathe et moi avons été donc ont
contacté par par tropiques atrium pour
cet événement qui s'appelle tropisme
poétique donc première partie emea gars
et en deuxième partie je vais proposer
un une performance qui s'appelle fonda
ce matin c'est quelque chose d'un peu
conceptuel beaucoup basé sur le tambour
sur la danse je serai accompagné de 2,20
coach et j'ai envie de dire par robert
regina le chorégraphe qui valent à kim
quand même temps fait la mise en scène
et puis au niveau musical par sully
cally au tombeau mêlait et josé zébina
qui va jouer de la samba qui va jouer du
40 qu'il sera pas les uns sa batterie
alors on va tous mourir voilà absolument
district et à la salle frantz fanon
tropica tri entre puis l'atrium à
fort-de-france voilà nicolas cage sur
scène merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
émission réalisée par idi le curieux
clerville
[Musique]